hmm time once again for leftovers this
is the segment where you watch me eat
for 40 minutes straight
read the jokes we didn't use this week
and like any leftovers until you dig in
you never know if they're any good or
just plain terrible and as always this
is my first time reading these all right
here we go this week during an interview
on news Nation former CNN anchor Chris
Cuomo announced he's accepted a job at a
fledgling Network I watched a few
minutes and thought Cuomo was pretty
good then I finished filling up my gas
tank and drove away
nice
but it was nice to see news Nation
finally broadcasting in color
I can't have them all Chris's brother
Andrew has also accepted a new TV job
I'm looking for him on the QVC selling
his new brand of nipple rings
though he says the senior discount will
no longer be available
black family is suing Sesame Place
alleging some of their costume
characters ignored their daughter based
on her race President Biden chimped in
saying any excuse for ignoring a little
girl doesn't pass the sniff test
all this comes after Sesame Street
controversially uh blame burden Ernie
for spreading monkey pox
the makers of Grand Theft Auto announced
they're releasing a sixth version of the
hit game now with the ability to play as
a female character which will make it
even more realistic now that it's a
woman crashing the car
[Applause]
I disowned that this past weekend a
group of Nazi protesters showed up
outside a turning point USA convention
organizers tried to remove them but they
were on public property and you can't
tell the FBI what to do
wow Zing God that's good JetBlue has
agreed to purchase Spirit Airlines for
3.8 billion dollars Aviation and
business experts say JetBlue overpaid by
3.8 billion dollars
these are good also the deal was
expected to go through immediately but
it's still stuck in Fort Lauderdale
[Applause]
this week the New York Times wrote on
the trend of cannibalism and
contemporary fiction which means the
media thinks we'll soon be hungry enough
to start eating each other
the good news I'll finally get that
five-star Michelin rating from my ass
new survey finds that one in three admit
stealing a co-worker's food from the
office refrigerator the other two-thirds
are damn Liars kill Mead
according to a new study get that
picture off a low libido has been added
to the list of symptoms of long covid
said Jill Biden thank God
this week John Hinckley tweeted his
support for abortion which is not
surprising considering he supports
killing people during the first term
wow
that is gold
a new study claims that dogs with white
sounding names get adopted from shelters
faster than dogs with black sounding
names but my dog Adolf already knew that
uh we're the best
finally Subway restaurants are offering
free sandwiches for life to the first
person who gets a foot long tattoo which
is a lot better than when Jared
offers free sandwiches to see anyone's
foot long
[Applause]
those are pretty damn good
gotta say that was a batch don't go away
we'll be right back hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else